Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Buonasera.
Siete delusi.
Cosa vi aspettavate?
Uno alto biondo con gli occhi azzurri?
Purtroppo il criterio bellezza,
nella selezione delle Frecce Tricolori,
non era stato ancora incluso.
Quando sono arrivato io, infatti,
mi sono sempre dovuto
portare dietro il casco
per dimostrare che ero io.
Però poi, alla fine, quando venivano
a chiedermi la foto,
mi mettevo in posa orgoglioso,
e loro mi dicevano
“ma non con te, con il casco”.
Quindi ero invidioso.
Detto questo, avevo giurato
che non avrei usato questo inizio:
ma mi piaceva troppo,
per cui ho iniziato così
anche questa sera;
e pensavate fossi una persona seria, vero?
Vi svelerò un segreto:
so anche essere serio.
E la prima cosa che voglio fare
è ringraziarvi.
Ringraziare l'organizzazione;
ringraziare il Comune di Fermo;
ringraziare tutti voi,
che la sera della partita dell'Italia
avete deciso di venire ad ascoltare noi.
Dovete sapere che questo
è il mio quarto TEDx,
tra l'Italia e l'estero;
eppure io sono sempre emozionato.
E sapete perché accetto sempre di venire?
Perché imparo.
Io ascolto gli altri e imparo:
ho imparato dai primi speaker,
imparerò da quelli che vengono dopo.
Quindi questa è sempre un'occasione
di grande, grande crescita.
Comunque, detto questo,
ma quanto è bello essere tutti qui?
Dal vivo.
Poterci guardare, poterci sorridere,
poterci dire ciao, poterci dire grazie
e poterci dire scusa;
poterci, con le dovute precauzioni,
dare le mani o addirittura abbracciarci.
Quanto è bello questo aspetto umano.
Per questo, oggi, ho deciso
che l'idea che volevo portarvi
è relativa ai valori,
che esistono anche nei mondi
ad alte prestazioni.
Esistono nel business, secondo me.
Io sono una persona
estremamente pragmatica, credetemi:
la mia vita è questo,
e ve la racconto in breve.
Però ho sempre agito
secondo i miei valori;
e in determinate situazioni,
in determinati team,
i valori sono la cosa più importante
perché è chiaro che, per avere successo,
bisogna essere competenti,
bisogna essere bravi oppure avere talento.
Ma quello che fa la differenza
è il modo in cui ci comportiamo,
e oggi noi abbiamo una grande opportunità
di recuperare molti
di questi aspetti umani.
La solidarietà, l'altruismo,
il chiedersi scusa,
il dirsi ti voglio bene,
perché funzionano anche in quei mondi
dove magari si può pensare
che si possa andare avanti
solo con la forza, l'arroganza,
essendo sempre forti,
però perché sbagliamo certe volte
a interpretare la parola valori.
Comunque io sono un sognatore,
uno che ha sempre immaginato
quello che voleva fare.
E, coerentemente coi valori
che mi sono stati dati,
in primis dalla mia famiglia,
sono andato avanti,
non sono mai neanche stato rallentato.
Anzi, qualche volta
ho vinto delle battaglie
proprio con quella che io chiamo
l'"estrema educazione":
Volevo fare il pilota,
sono diventato un pilota.
Sono entrato alle Frecce tricolori,
sono stato tantissimi anni lì,
ho volato come gregario, leader -
il leader è la punta
delle frecce, l'avete vista.
Io ho volato un sacco di volte,
adoro questa terra,
ho volato un sacco di volte
davanti qua a Fermo.
Era una delle missioni che amavamo di più,
perché nelle Marche
ci siamo sempre divertiti un sacco,
Comunque, il leader
gestisce il volo, da gli ordini,
è la voce che avete sentito,
le Frecce tricolori
sono la pattuglia acrobatica
più numerosa del mondo.
Dieci velivoli che volano
a due metri circa l'uno dall'altro,
molto veloci, 600 - 650 chilometri orari,
un sacco di G e molto bassi.
Poi sono diventato il comandante,
il comandante delle Frecce
ahimè non è più pilota,
esce dalla formazione,
non gioca la partita la domenica;
ma è l'amministratore delegato
dell'azienda Frecce Tricolori
che è un'azienda completa, c'è tutto:
dal magazzino, i soldi,
il comandante delle Frecce
ha il potere di spesa
ed è datore di lavoro e il responsabile
per il raggiungimento della missione,
che è quello di supportare
il sistema Paese all'estero.
Quindi, spesso,
dietro le missioni all'estero
delle Frecce Tricolori
in realtà ci sono motivi
o politici, diplomatici,
o di supporto al sistema Paese.
E io ho affrontato
personaggi come Gheddafi.
in una famosa missione,
che fu un caso internazionale nel 2009,
quando le frecce vennero mandate in Libia;
e l’ho affrontato secondo i miei valori,
difendendo la nostra bandiera,
perché lui non voleva
che noi usassimo i fumi tricolori
ma solo il fumo verde,
che era il colore della sua bandiera.
Quindi con la coerenza,
ma il rispetto e l'educazione,
anche in una situazione del genere
ho portato a casa il risultato.
Poi, lasciate le frecce,
ho avuto una fortuna enorme:
sono andato a lavorare
per una delle aziende
più famose del mondo, più importanti,
ho lavorato in Formula 1 per due anni
e ho lavorato nella
Direzione Risorse Umane,
dove mi sono occupato di un argomento
che si chiama cultura aziendale,
che non è altro che il comportamento,
è la materia che si occupa
del comportamento delle persone
nelle aziende, e quindi nelle squadre.
E indovinate cosa c'è,
alla base di questa materia?
I valori, i comportamenti.
Ho fatto un progetto straordinario,
sono stato il responsabile
di riscrivere la vision, la mission
e i valori di questa azienda.
Poi sono diventato il gestore
della funzione aziendale,
che si occupa di gestire -
scusate, i rischi dell'azienda,
in un'epoca in cui il rischio
più grande che possiamo correre
è non correre alcun rischio,
perché si sono accorciati
i cicli di vita di prodotto,
si sono accorciati
i cicli di vita delle competenze.
Stare fermi è la cosa più pericolosa
che possiamo fare oggi,
nel business e nella vita.
Poi ho deciso di lasciare Ferrari.
Ho messo su una mia piccola
azienda di consulenza,
ora sono amministratore delegato
di un'azienda del settore
aerospazio-difesa
e sono nel consiglio di amministrazione
di un'importantissima
società di assicurazioni.
E sono persino entrato nel corpo docente
di uno dei master
più importanti del mondo,
che è erogato da tre università straniere
e rispetto una delle regole
più importanti: lavoro a New York.
Quindi non sono proprio la persona
al quale voi magari abbinereste
la predica relativa
a valori, educazione, rispetto.
E invece io sono quella persona lì,
e tutto quello che avete visto
in mondi diversi, con competenze diverse,
mondi estremamente competitivi,
perché stiamo parlando tutti
di mondi "Numeri Uno",
dove tutti pensano
di essere il numero uno.
Io ho combattuto tutte le mie battaglie
basandomi su questi valori:
i primi me li ha dati mio papà,
quindi io sono partito da lì,
sono stato fortunato.
E mio papà diceva:
"Dovrai sempre lavorare duro".
Guarda caso, per le cose difficili
bisogna lavorare, non ti arrivano addosso.
"Dovrai essere leale
verso chi si fida di te -
e in poche parole ti paga lo stipendio -
e dovrai essere onesto".
Più un altro valore
che mi tengo per ultimo,
perché secondo me è il più importante.
Ma i valori di cui voglio parlarvi oggi
sono principalmente due.
Il primo è il rispetto.
Parolone: dobbiamo rispettarci,
non ci rispettiamo,
"una volta c'era più rispetto".
Attenzione, però,
perché io non rispetto una persona
perché si veste come me,
o fa il tifo per la stessa
squadra di calcio.
Potremmo commettere un gravissimo errore.
Io rispetto una persona
per il suo comportamento,
perché è capace di capire
dove finisce la sua libertà
e dove inizia la mia,
per cui non mi mette la macchina lì,
così io non posso andare a lavorare.
Rispetto vuol dire che io sono capace
ad esprimere la mia opinione
in maniera rispettosa;
ma soprattutto, sono capace di ascoltare
un'opinione diversa dalla mia
in maniera rispettosa.
E sapete cosa ho imparato io,
cambiando tantissimi lavori
nettamente diversi?
Che il lavoro degli altri è facile
solo fino a quando non tocca a te farlo.
Quindi rispetto per chi oggi
ha montato, preparato -
io non so fare quel lavoro.
Io, ogni volta che ho messo le mani
nel lavoro di qualcun altro,
ho capito quanto fosse difficile.
Rispetto è a una parola importantissima,
che dobbiamo sempre ricordare.
Essere rispettosi
non vuol dire essere deboli.
Rispetto è molto legato, secondo me,
a un'altra parola importantissima:
la parola educazione.
Essere educati non vuol dire
essere deboli.
Sapete come ho affrontato,
tutte le volte
che mi sono trovato di fronte
un arrogante prepotente
anche in ambiente lavorativo,
quelli che tentano di sovrastarti,
che parlano senza fermarsi,
sapete cosa facevo io?
Cosa ti insegnano alle elementari?
Io facevo così -
più basso eh, scusate se no.
Alzo la mano e sto zitto,
e lo guardo negli occhi però.
Lo guardo dritto negli occhi.
Tendenzialmente rimangono un po’:
oddio, cosa fa questo?
E io rispondo:
"Aspetto che tu abbia finito,
ti sia sfogato, poi parlo io".
Io ho sempre combattuto con queste armi.
E tendenzialmente, dopo aver stupito,
ho anche avuto la parola
e ho detto la mia.
Ma questo non vuol dire
essere deboli, anzi:
vuol dire avere pazienza, forza, fiducia.
E soprattutto farsi rispettare,
perché rispetto non è
solo verso gli altri.
Bisogna anche che sappiamo
farci rispettare.
Secondo valore: fiducia.
Anche questo è un parolone.
Non mi fido, non mi fido
di quella persona.
Poi gli chiedi: perché non ti fidi?
Non lo conosce neanche:
ha i capelli fucsia,
e quindi non gli piace.
Ma anche qui, io non
mi fido di una persona
perché fa il tifo
per la stessa squadra di calcio,
ama lo stesso tipo di pizza
o lo stesso tipo di film.
La fiducia non è questo,
la fiducia non è vestirsi
nello stesso modo;
soprattutto, sapete
che cosa non è la fiducia?
Che cosa non è la fiducia?
La fiducia non è pensarla
sempre nello stesso modo.
Anzi, se avete un amico che vi dice
che avete sempre ragione,
fatevi una domanda.
In ambito lavorativo,
se un collaboratore ti dice
che hai sempre ragione,
hai un problema.
Perché invece il valore
è la diversità di pensiero
esposta con rispetto.
Io ho una regola:
meno male che siamo tutti diversi.
Perché persone diverse
guardano lo stesso problema
da punti di vista diversi,
quindi riescono a estrapolare
tutti gli elementi
che per esempio un capo
deve prendere in considerazione
per prendere una decisione migliore.
Se io avessi problemi con le ragazze,
non riesco a trovarmi una ragazza,
vado al bar, bevo coi miei amici e piango:
"Le donne non mi capiscono".
È molto facile rispondere,
forse sarebbe la risposta più comune:
"Hai ragione le donne non ti capiscono",
e ti lasciano da solo tutta la vita.
L'amico vero, leale, rispettoso,
ti dice: "Massimo, permetti?
Forse ti ferirò, io devo dirti la verità
perché ti voglio bene.
Hai mai pensato che se ti facessi
la doccia tutti i giorni
potresti avere
qualche possibilità in più?"
Questo è l'amico vero:
nel mondo del lavoro,
questo è il collaboratore vero.
Leale, franco, ma rispettoso
della persona e dei ruoli.
La fiducia è un'altra cosa:
la fiducia è competenza,
empatia, sicuramente;
è affidabilità, quindi anche l'integrità;
soprattutto,
la fiducia è inversamente proporzionale
a una cosa bruttissima
che si chiama egoismo.
Dove essere altruisti, invece,
non vuol dire che vi do
il mio portafoglio.
Vuol dire che condivido,
vuol dire che insegno,
vuol dire che non penso
solo ai miei risultati,
vuol dire che non proietto
i risultati di un'azienda
sul trimestre solamente
perché è importante, per carità,
per la mia parte variabile di compenso,
ma penso anche a obiettivi a lungo termine
e penso alla sostenibilità
della mia squadra.
Questo, per esempio, è altruismo.
E poi c'è l'ultima parola.
Magica.
La parola che secondo me rappresenta
le fondazioni dei valori:
è la parola umiltà.
Umiltà non vuol dire non essere ambiziosi.
Ed è anche un po' diversa
dall'essere modesto:
non vuol dire essere uno zerbino
che accetta tutto.
Vuol solo dire che io conosco
e sono conscio di avere
dei punti di forza e delle competenze;
ma ho anche dei punti di debolezza
e delle aree di lacuna
in cui non sono preparato.
Vuol dire che quindi so
che per fare un grande team
devo avere dei collaboratori importanti.
Vuol dire che, se posso,
cerco anche di sceglierli migliori di me
perché se mi rispettano,
e mi faccio rispettare,
mi daranno un contributo
importantissimo alle mie decisioni.
Vuol dire che sono aperto di mente.
Vuol dire che, per esempio,
non darò mai per scontato
che il successo che ho avuto
finora come azienda
possa durare per sempre senza fare nulla.
Tutto quello che vi ho detto
ha un collante,
che si chiama comunicazione.
Come ci parliamo.
Beh, vi svelo un segreto:
io, quando parlo, mi capisco benissimo.
Non è altrettanto vero, o scontato,
che sia stato così bravo stasera
da passare tutti i messaggi.
La comunicazione è un gesto
di grande umiltà,
che richiede impegno:
non possiamo mai dare per scontato
che quello che diciamo sia capito,
e interpretato, come vogliamo noi.
E la domanda non è mai: hai capito?
Ma la domanda è: mi sono espresso bene?
Infine, vi ho detto che sono un sognatore.
Anche i nostri sogni
devono essere coerenti ai valori.
Perché spesso oggi i nostri sogni,
i sogni delle persone,
sono effimeri, sono pilotati,
guidati da quello
che dice il nostro mondo.
Mentre io e il mio amico Andrea,
amici d'infanzia, quando eravamo giovani,
e io ero già uno che
"io spaccherò, io farò, io diventerò",
lui mi diceva: "Ma perché?"
E io: "Tu non hai ambizioni".
Lui mi dice: “Certo che ho ambizioni,
io ho queste ambizioni:
una bella moglie, una bella figlia,
una casa di proprietà,
un lavoro dal lunedì al venerdì
a un chilometro da casa
e la domenica voglio
guardarmi la partita”.
Andrea è riuscito in tutto questo.
Ha ottenuto tutti questi risultati:
ha una bella moglie, posso testimoniare;
ha una bella figlia,
lo posso testimoniare;
ha una bella casa,
lavora dal lunedì al venerdì
a un chilometro e mezzo da casa.
E ha Sky.
Quindi chi è l'eccellente, tra me e lui?
Il mio amico è un eccellente
e non si è fatto fregare
dall'amico ambizioso.
Aveva le idee chiare, coerenti,
ha raggiunto i suoi obiettivi.
Perché poi, alla fine,
tu puoi essere anche
il comandante delle Frecce
ma se non hai un affetto, e un amico,
sei uno str… qualunque.